[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning the
decision on
when and if former president trump will
be allowed
on facebook is back in the hands of the
person who least seemed to want it in
the first place that would be the
company's ceo mark zuckerberg
he created an independent oversight
board paid for by facebook
which ruled yesterday that the company
was right to suspend mr trump for
inciting the crowd
that attacked the capitol in january but
it also said facebook was wrong to
impose
an indefinite suspension and the board
gave the company
six months to permanently ban mr trump
or
set a date to restore his account this
was a fraudulent
election four months after former
president trump posted
this video with false claims of election
fraud
and then sympathized on social media
with supporters who stormed the capitol
that very day
hella thorning schmidt and other members
of facebook's oversight board said
it was up to facebook not its
self-created committee
to decide what to do with the former
president's accounts
we upheld a facebook decision from the
7th of january where they
took mr trump off the platforms and we
said that was the right
decision because mr trump's
content actually created harm real life
harm so
that was the right decision but we also
said to facebook that they couldn't just
invent
an arbitrary penalty instead the board
gave facebook
six months to pick a penalty for
president trump that is
consistent with facebook's rules for
severe violations
facebook for its part said it will now
consider the board's decision
and determine an action that is clear
and proportionate
but in the meantime the former president
remains locked out of his facebook and
instagram accounts
and off all major social media platforms
after a permanent ban by twitter
and an indefinite suspension by youtube
so he responded on an old-fashioned
website
saying free speech has been taken away
from the president of the united states
some of the former president's allies
took to cable news
it's wrong and it's hurting america
while others of course turn to social
media
describing the ruling as disgraceful and
pathetic
house minority leader kevin mccarthy
accused facebook of
acting like a democrat super pac
facebook
is often accused in particular by
republicans of making
partisan decisions suppressing content
that is conservative
in nature in reviewing this case did you
see evidence of that
we didn't but that is why the board is
so
adamant that the decisions that are
taking are not taking on an arbitrary
in an arbitrary way it has to be based
on
clarity clarity that rules apply
equally for everyone and of course
transparency
it's all really new this space emily
bazelon is a writer for the new york
times magazine
and lecturer at yale law school facebook
is a private company
it is not um the public square the first
amendment
kind of traditional very broad
protections for free speech don't apply
she says that while someone may need to
regulate speech on facebook
there's no agreement on whether that
should be silicon valley
or the government and so that's really
the choice that's at stake here it's
about corporations
making key decisions about the freedom
of expression
and preventing harm from spreading
online versus
people who we elect the problem of
course with handing this power over to
the government
is you always have to imagine any tool
you create for controlling speech in the
hands of
the next person who you don't like who
gets elected for now
facebook's oversight board is also
asking for some self-reflection
inviting the company to review its own
potential role
in the tensions that led to the capital
riot
what's to stop facebook from reading
your the board's decision
and doing nothing putting it into a
drawer closing the drawer and never
looking at it again
they can't do nothing because we have
given them six months to react and we
want them to look at our recommendation
and
change their content policy so they
become clearer
and we have of course expect facebook to
to honor
their commitment uh to the oversight
group i mean the reality is that
facebook does have a choice here it can
take action or it cannot it's up to them
now the board is supposed to be
independent of facebook and it includes
prominent lawyers journalists and former
government officials
like thornton schmidt there who is the
former prime minister of denmark
facebook reportedly pays board members
guys about six figure
salaries i think what's so unsatisfying
to just about everybody i mean no one
seems happy with this
is the board is saying facebook cannot
invent a penalty
but then it said to facebook please
invent some policies
make a decision so either you're
comfortable with a corporation making
this decision
or you want a government to make this
decision or but nobody seems to want
nobody to make
the decision so it's like a rock a hard
place and another hard place
so next move mark zuckerberg he's got to
do something for for years he's been
saying i don't want to be an arbiter of
truth
i don't want to police but what you
understand of this do you
his reluctance is totally relatable but
it's going to come down to him
it's a big call right now wait